جدا لا نستطيع ان
نتحرك 80% من سيارات الاسعاف تم توقفها
بالكامل كما تشاهدون اكثر من سياره عننا
تقريبا متوقفه غير عن ذلك تقريبا فوق فوق
ال سياره اسعاف تم استهدافها وتم اتلافها
لا تسطح عمل نهائيا لا يوجد بنزين لا يوجد
سولر سياراتنا نصها تنكات سولر بالعافيه
بنروح صرنا احنا نجيب نشتري شريا ويصعب
الوصول الى السلر حتى عننا سيارات كمان في
قطاع غزه المركزيه اصبحت 90% من سيارتها
متوقفه فش ل سيارتين ثلاثه الليج عننا
وصرنا ننا نغطي كمان غزه والشمال صنا نحمل
في الاسعاف ما يقارب فوق ال 20
اصابه ا ماشي حا بالنسبه لضباط الاسعاف
كنا منهارين نفسيا وضعنا وضعنا كارثي وصعب
جدا سيارات الاسعاف في قطاع غزه لا
يعني الوقود نسبه الوقود فيها صعبه جدا
جدا جدا بنعاني احيانا بنعرض بنعرض حالنا
للخطر نروح على محطات حدوديه بنروح على
محطات حدوديه عشان نقدر نعبي سياره
الاسعاف ومن خاطره مخاطره وحاله صعبه
عيشها سكان الحصول على السولار من خلال
المحطات البنزين التي تقع في المناطق
الخطره في مناطق صلاح الدين وانا شخصيا
ذهبت الى هذا المكان الذي لا يكاد يصله
انسان هنا استهدا نعاني معاناه شديده بسبب
صعوبه الاتصالات وانقطاع الجوال
والارسال المتعمد في عدم يعني توصيل هذا
يعني يؤدي الى عدم التواصل بين المصابين
على ارض الميدان وبين ضبط الاشاره المتلقي
المكالمه بالتالي يمكن ان نعرف مكان
الاصابه من خلال الدخان المتصاعد ثم نتوجه
الى المكانه يستغرق اكثر من ع الى ربع
ساعه وهذا يؤدي الى هلاك اكبر قدر من
المواطنين بالعاف قعدنا نطلع النس في حدا
اج هنا واكثر الاصابات بسبب صمود السكان
وال المواطنين في بيوت في المناطق
الحدوديه يحاولون الاتصال بنا بعد فتره من
الاتصال يمكن يعني ان منهم الاشاره لكن
ايضا نجد صعوبه في تردد
بعض المسعفين بسبب خطوره الموقف فمنا من
يعني يعني يجاهد وينطلق يعني الى الميدان
ومنا من يعني تاخذه الرحه لكن الموقف رهيب
ومخيف جدا شايفين بعينيكم غير الله بس
غير اقوللك كل في 50 نفر في الدار هذ يا
عمي
r